we are with atalia Cervantes after an
important Victory back-to-back victories
for you Talia and an important one
against Sabina a wild one as well you at
some point play this move Bishop to H6
out of nowhere tell us about your
feelings right now
all right I'm glad that I had this game
it was very exciting kind of breaks from
the
um well I already broke from my sequence
of draws but I break from that from that
style a little bit
um yes and probably that Quincy one
Bishop H6 is probably one of the
weirdest move sequence I've played
um
here I felt like my position was nice
out of the opening and yes so I was
thinking for a very long time I assumed
it was winning but I wasn't sure exactly
how this was the critical move which is
quite difficult and the idea is that you
go here
all right let me remember
do you guys remember the idea I think it
was something like this G3 and if you go
King h8 now I have Queen right and I
attack here tonight I think I noticed
that those ideas after playing Queen C1
because I think after Queen C1
um for example I thought that
let's just say Knight H7 yes and
um Rook G3 King a shade I don't think is
possible because then I have Queen C3
stuff Quincy so I saw that type of idea
maybe a little too late
um but I I mean I assumed it was winning
I just couldn't figure out how but still
very nice move after this H5 especially
from a practical perspective she only
had nine minutes on her clock 20 moves
to go and you played this move which
page six what oh it's actually not
losing I'm glad
no no it's actually a draw but
and I think she made one mistake and you
capitalize on it immediately Queen to F6
Rook to H4 and this move work to d8 she
was supposed to go Queen to G6
yeah so I imagine Queen G6 and Bishop V3
and then
um
I knew that my attack was gone but okay
I have a pawn and we're on time travel
and she has a lot less time than me so
you're feeling confident at this point
right I assume they would be good yeah
but after definitely after rug of the
bishop G7 everything just seems to fall
apart yeah
and this end game is winning I don't
know if I play the best way but I mean
once you start pushing the H Pawn and I
think trading just a pair of books is
good there's no stopping that Queen and
two pawns against uh rook and a bishop
she's probably not going to find the
Fortress Thalia congratulations big uh
back-to-back victory for you and uh
we'll see you in the remainder of your
games thank you so much well done tell
you indeed and uh